uh brandon judd is the border patrol
union president uh brandon i have a
feeling we could be seeing a lot more of
these flights and or buses of those
trying to find their way here beyond
texas uh how do you feel about that that
that process
has not been interrupted in fact it's
picking up considerable steam
nil every single one of my agents in my
and myself we're extremely upset we feel
beaten down we feel like this
administration has not given us the the
enforcement tools they've given us the
processing tools but they haven't given
us the enforcement tools to stop this
crisis that currently goes on in fact
when we process people through quicker
that just means more people are going to
continue to come that is inviting people
to come here we're hoping for the best
but there's been nothing from this
administration that has given us any
hope um
that there's going to be a light at the
end of the tunnel this just continues to
get worse and worse and worse and the
american public is paying for it you
know brandon um
i always wonder what will come of this
decision whether they will just remove
this title 42 suspension or just suspend
the suspension you know what i mean like
push it back another month or so that
won't help you in any way
no it doesn't we've already seen what
happens when you cut out segments um as
bill was reporting down there on in del
rio when we cut out segments when we
give carve outs to venezuelans cubans
colombians which by the way we do not
exercise title 42 on any of those
countries that just invites more people
to come so when you look at that right
now we're only expelling about 55
percent of the people that cross the
border illegally
once that goes away completely that just
means everybody from around the world
are going to continue to come so it's
just a band-aid to push it back what we
have to have is we have to have
permanent solutions and neil you and i
have both talked about what those
solutions are and the biden
administration knows what they need to
do they just fail to do it they will not
put this um the proper enforcement tools
in place because they pander to their
far left open border base do you know
brandon whether uh
the administration if it were to get its
way a stop title 42 the on the 23rd
that they're going to beef up uh
manpower woman power on the border with
your people to to deal with what even
they acknowledge could be an increase
and likely a significant increase to
your point in in migrants trying to get
through
no i've never been more disappointed in
a plan than what i saw from dhs that six
pillar plan all it's talking about is
moving people through the system faster
it's not talking about any enforcement
tools except for pillar number three
where they say it's going to be
expedited removal but it's already been
proven under the obama administration
that expedited removal doesn't work
because all somebody has to do is claim
that they have a fear of going back to
their country then that order that
expedited removal order is cancelled and
they're put through the uh the
the asylum process and released into the
united states so nothing in those
pillars
doesn't give enforcement tools all it's
doing is talking about moving people
through the system faster and that
doesn't work that just encourages more
illegal immigration wild stuff brandon i
know you keep up with it but you do
young man thank you brandon john the
border patrol union president i went to
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now